let's see if we can figure out what the
limit of x squared plus one over sine of
x is as x approaches infinity
so let's just think about what's going
on in the numerator and then think about
what's going on in the denominator so
the numerator we have x squared plus one
so as x gets larger and larger and
larger as it approaches infinity well
we're just squaring it here so it's
going to this numerator is going to get
even
approach infinity even faster so this
thing is going to go to infinity as x
approaches infinity now what's happening
to the denominator here well sine of x
we've seen this before sine of x and
cosine of x are bounded they oscillate
they oscillate between negative 1 and 1.
so negative 1 is going to be less than
or equal to
sine of x which is going to be less than
or equal to 1. so this denominator is
going to oscillate so what does that
tell us well we might be tempted to say
well the numerator is unbounded goes to
infinity and then the denominator is
just oscillating between these values
here so maybe the whole thing goes to
infinity but we have to be careful
because one this denominator is going
between positive and negative values so
this the numerator is just going to get
more and more and more positive but
we're being divided sometimes by
positive values sometimes by a negative
value so we're gonna we're gonna jump
between positive and negative positive
and negative and then you also have all
these crazy asymptotes here every time x
every time x uh every time sine of x
becomes zero
well then you're going to be you're
going to have a vertical asymptote this
thing will not be defined so you're
going to have all these vertical
asymptotes you're going to oscillate
between positive and negative and
just larger and larger values and so
this limit does not exist so does not
exist
does
not
exist
and we can see that graphically we've
described it in words just inspecting
this expression but we can see it
graphically if we actually look at a
graph of this
which i have right here and you can see
that as x goes towards positive infinity
as x goes to positive infinity
we depending on which x we are we're
kind of going we go we get really large
then we had a vertical asymptote that we
jumped back down got really negative
vertical asymptote up down up down up
down it just is the oscillations just
get more and more extreme but we keep
having these
vertical asymptotes on a periodic basis
so it's very clear that this limit does
not exist